this debate is going to look at the
question of morality the vexed question
of morality and politics and whether we
actually want our politicians to take
moral positions do we believe them if
they do and if they do does morality
favor the left or the right does history
favor the left or the right so all
politicians think they're in the right
don't even the most realistic when
challenged defend their positions on
moral grounds on my immediate left we
have Kris Bryant's Labour MP for the
Rhondda and my right Sophie Walker
founding leader of the women's equality
party Phil Collins who you may have seen
on your list is sadly not able to join
us he's unwell today Peter Hitchens as
you see is very much present columnist
for The Mail on Sunday let's look at the
question of where their history morality
favor the left or the right which which
do you think it is Chris well I suppose
I I'm an ex used to be a vicar I'm an ex
vicar though the Daily Mail once
described me as an ex-gay vicar and
witch and the gay thing is coming along
quite nicely actually and a in fact in
fact I'm a practicing homosexual and one
day I'll probably be quite good at it or
at least my husband certainly hope so
and but so I suppose I ought to be
arguing that that you know God favors
the left and I I helped run the
Christian Socialist Movement for several
years and and but I I think it's
actually very dubious whether you come
from a Christian perspective or any
other to presume that you have all of
the moral high ground you may have good
arguments that are based on ethical
considerations but handing out
membership cards for any political party
to the individual members of the Holy
Trinity I think is a mistake however my
biggest anxiety at the moment is that
there is a version of politics which is
deliberately amoral that is to say and I
think some people in politics
the moment around the world have decided
that if you lie at least 40% will
believe you so you might as well have
those 40% so you might as well lie I
think that is the fundamental assumption
behind Donald Trump I think it's the
assumption behind for instance President
Putin in relation to Salisbury III which
I simply don't understand how a Russian
- Russian man who looked at remotely
like a gay couple to me and could come
to Salisbury and be put off by the snow
having only just left Moscow but I think
that that was deliberate it was
deliberate that nobody should believe
them because that was part of putting
two fingers up to Britain and I think
that that it's an essential part of the
way that Putin does his politics I've
just come back from China and where I
was on a visit with the Foreign Affairs
Committee and we met with a member of
the Politburo you know one of the 25 men
who runs China and his whole political
posture was amoral it was just about the
economy nothing more than that
and you know we raised various other
issues and he was simply not interested
so so I would argue that you do have to
have a morality I get a bit and worried
about people on moral Crusades because
if you believe in yourself too much and
you don't have an element of doubt
there's a danger I think that you become
a demagogue the classic instance of this
is not political at all but a friend of
mine was driving me to a by-election and
I said you sure this is the right route
and he said I'm 100% certain and I
that's what worried me because when
somebody a hundred percent certain it
seems to me they haven't taken into
consideration the possibility that they
might be wrong and those are the most
dangerous people of all so elite and he
was wrong it was wrong of course
so a lake bid for thee for the virtues
of doubt say I'm an Anglican after all
history morality on the side of the left
or the right okay so I'm gonna have a go
answering the question mmm yeah
so I think both sides often I mean
always they claim to delivering progress
but from where I'm sitting I suppose
it's it's a plague on both houses
because both left and right the morality
that they present damages women's lives
and so long as we have history books and
morality lessons written by men
institutions ruled and governed by men
economic templates written to the male
experience I mean Adam Smith is the
ultimate right his irony free
declaration of man's self-interested man
while he sort of was had his meals
brought by his mother you know basically
this this is this for me is the is the
overarching issue which is that both
sides are bring a morality that doesn't
see women so on the right we've got a
system that prizes family values
conservatism based on very narrow and
quite oppressive views about what
families should be so white middle-class
heteronormative but you but from that
position you can still support and pass
laws on for example gay marriage because
it follows views on the sanctity of
marriage and a sort of emulation of
heteronormativity if you like and from
the right the mark that sort of morality
allows women to thrive when they fall
within conservative values so I'd this
idea of a meritocracy for example where
women can make it to be prime minister
if they're if they're just as good as
men if they try harder they can get
further and this declaration that you
know the right it does better for women
because they've had two female prime
ministers without sort of examining the
idea that two women in in two hundred
years is probably not that much of a
meritocracy but on the right it's when
women fall outside of that very narrow
vision of morality that women are
punished so to child limits on a child
tax credit perfect example of punishing
families that don't meet conserved
values hits black and Asian families the
hardest Runnymede trust I think yes in
the women's Budget Group sure that the
combination of cuts and changes to
universal credit would hit black women
the most leaving the 5,000 pounds worth
of a year on average
I know it's interesting because I think
then this strong moral attachment to
Family Values does mean that the right
can pass useful legislation that
recognizes for example violence against
women and girls criminalizing female
genital mutilation revenge porn the
bringing of the domestic abuse bill but
only because that violence is seen as
egregious to the morality of family and
as anomalous episodes rather than as a
result of structural inequality that
women experience and that's why the
forthcoming domestic violence bill is so
slim which is a huge disappointment
coming from Teresa mais government what
is good about it is that it makes abuse
in front of children and an aggravating
factor it strengthens family law courts
but there is no funding additional
funding ring-fenced funding protected
sustainable sufficient funding for the
services run by and for women living
with an escaping from male violence and
of course the right has presided over
austerity that has made poor women even
poorer disproportionately being paid for
by women 86% of it has been paid by
women now on the left of course we have
as Jeremy JC was saying yesterday the
left is the party of women left as the
party of equality I disagree
fundamentally with this because the left
has a structural analysis and a morality
that is limited very much to class and
particularly in this latest incarnation
can't see any oppression that's not
Western and capitalist and that is why
in the past for example men on the left
of condoned FGM as a cultural practice
because they don't see the oppression of
black and Asian women by black and Asian
men it doesn't fit into their structural
class analysis the left is obsessed with
working-class men's jobs jeremy corbyn's
to this summer though his made in
britain brexit plan that affirms his
50-year focus on manufacturing which is
frankly a slap in the face to millions
of women who disproportionately employed
in service sector do you know what how
the Treasury classifies a woman
our mother raising two children and
caring for an elderly parent
economically unproductive economically
inactive inactive and the left doesn't
have an answer to that because it
ignores the vast amount of work unpaid
and low paid care work that women do and
I think you know we're going to talk
about morality of equality we need I
would expect labor not just to want to
nationalize everything from where we
store water to energy to Royal Mail but
actually to do something about Social
Care which has an 80% female workforce
and is absolutely on its knees so yeah I
mean the center-left has made some
progress particularly on representation
but in the 2015 election it was a huge
disappointment to me to see the left did
not make a case against austerity
despite it being evidence at that point
that women were disproportionately
paying for it it just bargained with
itself over how much more of it we could
take thank you it is your turn a plague
on both the houses and and does history
morality favor the left or the right
I Kris is the next Vicar I'm a next
rockiest what when I was a Trotsky of
course I had no morals at all please
join me in thanking so if you will cook
describe and key
you